[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who can
figure out exactly what we're deep with
you're not suggest new I think you're
suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I know
I'm wrong
mommy charge allow me to clarify in a
sequentially ranked hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
quantify agent stone the doctor thinks
you're basic
listen pal I don't know if you realize
I'm sorry major what was your name
benjoe nobody cares
[Music]
meow basically it looks like I'm gonna
have to save your planet no but thank
you for asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
security neutralize it see what makes it
tick
[Music]
look at this I took 9 million steps
today
stay in there and be quiet how much
longer I keep three even here do you
have your child in that bag no I mean
yes it's a child but it's not lying it's
not your child
smells like bodies bring an old ham
sandwich
[Music]
[Music]